singularity is part thought experiment
and part useful
um idea for drumming up publicity for
artificial intelligence and thereby
getting more money
the idea is that you attempt to get
computers to
work on a more human level by um
being able to learn and infer uh
and act in a more human kind of way
the underlying idea is that if this gets
to a point
where computers equal um humans
then because they are running on
um a substrate that is arguably
more powerful um than an actual brain
that they'll
then start to outstrip us and the
technology will probably
at that time be around for them to start
redesigning themselves
because humans can design artificial
intelligence and if it gets the point
it's as good as a human then
ai can design ai
that this will get out of control and uh
computers and robots will add strippers
completely and
depending on the uh uh what you listen
to
um and how how much they want to push
the uh catastrophic line
um will end up killing us all or
recycling us for
uh for our component parts or or
whatever
um and that's that tends to be the way
that it's presented
it's much easier to present a
catastrophe than it is to present
friendly ai which is uh what i somehow
suspect is more likely
do you believe this is something that we
will ever get to or ever see
over a long enough time scale i think
that
human level artificial intelligence is
completely inevitable
if humanity hangs around for long enough
and continues to progress in what it can
do
then if you wait for long enough
as has been said before um can you make
a machine think
sure i'm a machine and i can think at
some point
it seems clear that uh human built
machines get to a level of
being as good as us and possibly
outstripping us
the the point of contention then is how
long does it take
and there are fairly um widely differing
views on
the time scale that's actually involved
ever since ami really got started in the
1950s
it's the full human level ai has always
been
apparently on the horizon and has never
um
quite appeared because it's just so hard
now well i've been asked so many times
to talk about this um in recent months
that i sort of went back and tried to
find
some good examples to give and i found
an absolute cracker which is i'm
i'm quoting claude shannon in computer
science circles claude shannon
is of the same kind of level as einstein
shannon is responsible for information
theory
without which you have no internet no
mobile phones
pretty much know nothing um and so this
man is a
giant in computer science so this is
this is him talking in 1961.
i confidently expect that within a
matter of 10 or 15 years
something will emerge from the
laboratories which is not too
far from the robots of science fiction
fame
so you know many people who've have made
this mistake before
and if you look at ai research you find
that in the 50s
people are saying it's on the horizon um
and then when it didn't deliver
everything died down
and ai became deeply unfashionable
then you had something called the the
fifth generation computing project
which was really heavily funded in japan
and they said they were going to solve
ai by building big computers
that would run a particular programming
language called prologue very very fast
and that their their main aim was going
to be to make
um an ai that could play the game of go
um at a human level
this completely failed after
many years of work and an awful lot of
money
and at that point the hype cycle turned
again
and ai became deeply unfashionable um
and there's an interesting further point
there which is that there is still no
proper
um go player in ai that can beat genuine
human experts there's been some recent
progress that's brought it forward but
it's still not there
it's far harder than chess which is one
of the things that makes it interesting
so chess is on an 8x8 board
goes on a 19 by 19 board which makes
the space of possibilities vastly bigger
than chess i mean chess is essentially a
done
deal and even world champions now uh
accept this but go is much much harder
one of the
reasons that sometimes people put
forward um
for the idea that human level ai is just
around the corner is moore's law which
just says that
essentially every 18 months two years
give or take
you you get a doubling in how much
computer power you have
the thing is that that doesn't really
buy you much with
even something like the game of go
because yes you get an exponential
increase
in um how much computer power you have
go is 19 by 19. i think the branching
factor on average is about 250
which means that essentially if you want
to look one move further ahead
you need 250 times more computing power
if you want to look two moves ahead
the amount you need is 250 squared and
moore's law
just gets negated this same argument
would kill chess programs as well
okay if all you relied on was getting
more computing power
the reason that you can do good computer
chess is that the algorithms
are much cleverer there's a way that you
can almost
you know most of the time you can reduce
the number of possibilities that you
have to look through by very clever
um programming um
but the point is that getting more
computer power isn't enough you have to
be much cleverer in the way in which you
go about solving the problems now
whether
there's something um very fundamental in
the way that brains do computation
i suspect there is um because if you ask
a go
player what do you think of this
position they're not thinking
through all the ways of getting 10 moves
ahead
there's a there's a much more subtle
pattern recognition kind of thing going
on there
a lot of which is probably completely
subconscious
people might think of it as being their
gut feeling exactly yeah
they might and this comes up a lot um
it's a big problem in ai because one of
the approaches that
people have explored in order to do ai
is to try and get human experts to tell
them how to solve a problem
the trouble is that human experts can't
always articulate it
so you know that's a related thing
um but the yeah the the idea that you
just get more and more computer power
isn't enough you have to be really
clever in how you do the algorithms as
well
and the way in which brains actually do
it is just not on the whole very well
understood
people people don't really know what's
going on there it's not just a
philosophical
argument is it we literally don't
understand
is that am i right people know
a bit about how brains do certain things
but the really clever stuff
is a complete mystery from looking at
what happens when people get
bumps on the head um you know what
various bits of bits of brain actually
do
but if you when you look at the higher
kind of cognitive functions um
i mean i think my sort of favorite
example here is
our ability to um have a focus of
interest
okay by which i mean um
in our heads we have huge quantities of
information
and almost every single bit of it is
completely irrelevant right now
okay so i could be the world's biggest
expert on the
mating habits of the patagonian food bad
but the fact is i'm sitting here talking
to you on a
particular subject now i'm immediately
excluding
whatever i know about patagonian food
bats without
having to consciously think what bits do
i need to exclude and i'm excluding what
i know about and how to drive and eating
and drinking what i have for lunch and
all my memories about the last you know
34 years of my life
everything is unconsciously and
immediately
um filtered out and that's a big problem
for ai
software um because it doesn't have the
ability to do that
and the way in which your brain does
that as far as i'm aware
okay please if you're a
neurophysiologist and i'm wrong then
feel free to send me a snotty email
which i will then read and
with interest and ignore it oh yes
leave a comment yay
hashtag holden's talking rubbish um
i don't mind i'm thick skinned
but yeah a lot of what's what's going on
in there is is really not understood
and the the other there's another
important thing here which is um
which follows on from this idea of
increasing computing power
firstly moore's law as far as anyone can
tell is about to run out
it's going to run out very quickly
because
the circuitry in microchips is now
getting so small
that um reliability is becoming an issue
if you actually look at the size of the
things you're making
on a microprocessor now and you look in
comparison at how big a grain of dust is
a grain of dust transistor okay
um which is why you have to make these
things in clean rooms but you're getting
so
small now that it's giving the point
where you have to expend
energy in order to make sure that the
calculations the microprocessors are
doing are actually correct
um also there's a problem in that
microprocessor silicon chips
fundamentally basically a
two-dimensional
object and they have many layers in them
okay because you're layering up material
but fundamentally it's on a one
millimeter thick
um die now you could argue well let's
just go to three dimensions because
brains are three-dimensional
but there's no real really good way as
yet of fabricating
um microprocessors in three dimensions
you what tends to happen
is let's say one micro system probably
takes 150 watts of power
in a space that's about a couple of
centimeters by a couple of centimeters
and is flat
okay if you start stacking these up or
trying to fabricate in three dimensions
you have a problem getting rid of the
heat
now you then have the amazing fact that
your brain requires about 20 watts
this big old lump of stuff needs about
20 watts and it's all in three
dimensions and not only is it all in
three dimensions
it's massively more densely packed
um if you compare it to what people can
currently make using a technology
that is now coming up against the limit
of uh
how much you can actually pack in there
um
so not only do you not really understand
what a lot of what brains are doing
you can't make anything at the moment
that's
remotely as densely packed and connected
or remotely as energy efficient and
that's another reason i think
um the singularity the idea is actually
quite a long way off
because you can bang on about how fast
progress is
um is as much as you like but the fact
is that no one has any idea how to make
something that complicated
we'd like to thank audible.com for
sponsoring this episode of computer file
and if you like books get over to
audible.com slash computer file
and there's a chance to download one for
free they've got 180
000 titles to choose from so you're
bound to find something you like
and if you're interested as most
computer files probably are in
artificial intelligence the singularity
and the things we've been talking about
in this video check out machines of
loving grace
by john markoff it should be right up
your street
so thanks again to audible.com for
sponsoring this episode
of computer file it hijacks the world's
stamp printing factories or perhaps
it writes a virus and it hijacks all the
computers in the world to get all of the
printers in the world to do nothing but
print stamps
so building a model of the behavior of a
human
by watching the way they play gets you
into territories that are vastly harder
even than go